I have truly shocking news for you
Americans make up 4% of the world's
population but own 40% of all the guns
meaning that Americans are over
represented by 10 times in gun ownership
and what's actually shocking to me is
how low the number is because if you
consider how American gun culture is so
totally out of whack with gun culture in
most parts of the world I actually
wouldn't have been that surprised if
Americans had more than 50 or 60% of the
world guns and some other interesting
data from the study which was done by
the Graduate Institute of International
and Development studies in Geneva
Switzerland there are more than a
billion firearms on the planet 85% of
those are owned by civilians that's
about 850 million civilian guns about
400 million of those are in the United
States which is more than the number of
civilian owned firearms held by citizens
in the next 25 countries combined and
this is of course forgetting that there
are a ton of unregistered guns that
probably aren't even showing up in this
data in the United States and of course
you could make that same argument about
other countries as well the guns that
Americans own are also on average more
powerful than in other countries because
there's lots of firearms you can get in
the US that you cannot get at least not
legally in other countries so the good
news is that we are going to be very
very ready to defend ourselves if
government becomes tyrannical of course
the only problem is that our current
government has major tyrannical
tendencies and the people with the guns
actually seem to be in support of those
tyrannical tendencies and as I was
reading this data I thought about how
Americans relationship to guns is
similar to the American government's
relationship to nuclear weapons we have
roughly 4,000 nuclear weapons in the
United States or controlled by the
United States not all necessarily in the
United States we don't know that's
rivaled only by Russia orders of
magnitude more nukes than almost any
other country that has nuke as has nukes
has and of course most countries have
zero nukes altogether and it's just
something to brag about like having tons
guns in the same way that the four
hundred million guns will never be used
in the US in any realistic scenario the
four thousand Dukes nukes also aren't
going to be used there's no circumstance
where you need or could even use four
thousand nukes it's more than enough to
destroy the entire planet many times
over but yet the sort of jingoistic
nationalists love having more more MORE
whether it's nukes or guns and there is
a very similar sort of dynamic there so
given that there are more guns than
people in the United States can
conservatives rest easy that there won't
be any major confiscation program or
even like a gun buyback program because
no just not politically feasible any gun
control will be from any guns here
forward right everything else be
grandfathered in no no because all of
those extra guns you might say four
hundred million guns only three hundred
twenty five million people that includes
also toddlers and babies who presumably
wouldn't get guns
what about arming guerrillas guerrillas
share many traits with Homo sapiens and
you could absolutely train a gorilla to
own a to to fire a gun and help in the
defense against that tyrannical
government but back to reality you don't
become the most feared and powerful
nation in the world by stockpiling
flowers right it's by stockpiling guns
and some of the countries with the
fewest firearms by percentage are Japan
and Indonesia total beta [ __ ] countries
we have the guns and we are the
equivalent of the alpha male in
geopolitics think about where Americans
are over-represented around the world
four percent of the population and forty
percent of the gun it's got it four
percent of the population and 25 percent
of the world's known prison population I
know that some countries have people who
are imprisoned and it's not part of the
official numbers but four percent of the
population in the u.s. twenty five
percent of the known world prison
population not great
absolutely not great yeah I mean I kind
of wish we were number one in health
care and education
technological advancements but you know
this is a saving grace I guess we're
number one in guns keep wishing because
the
the areas where we excel our areas where
we would usually we compete with
countries we don't normally compare
ourselves to I think is the best way to
put it